hello everyone in this video we'll talk
about
subculturing technique which is used in
cell culture
and this video series is all about cell
culture
cell culture media its usage in research
so stay tuned till the end of this video
so
subculturing also known as passaging
means removal of the medium and
putting the cells into a fresh growth
medium which would allow them
to grow the main goal of this technique
is to ensure the cell gets the
environment for its proper growth
so when do you need to do subculturing
right
so when the cells are too much crowded
you can divide them into two groups
and subcultured them so this video is
divided in two segments
when to do a subculture and how to do a
subculture
let's begin with when to do a subculture
so the cells which are in the culture
media
they can grow nicely because nutrient
and growth factor is available
but the cell growth
would take place slowly it would go
through the log phase
and eventually reach the plateau phase
now the important aspect is in the
transition of
log and platophase when the cells are
reaching the plateau phase
then there would be too many cells for
the given amount of nutrients so first
of all the nutrient situation would be
limiting
and due to metabolism the cells would
produce a lot of toxic stuff that
can create problems in terms of their
growth
so too many cells is a problem
and that scientific term is called
confluency
now let me tell you the specific aspect
so these cells which are in the media
they would update glucose because media
has glucose if you don't know what is
the composition of cell culture media
you can click on the video in the link
in the i button
so after taking glucose it would release
the byproduct
in the media so the cell would take the
glucose
and the glucose would be converted to
pyruvate in the glycolytic pathway
that pyruvate can generate lactate and
this
lactic acid which is secreted out in the
media
can lower the ph of this media
now all of these cell culture media
comes with
ph indicator such as phenol red
which is generally 7.1
and it looks red when it's all right
but the problem is when there is
exhaustion of the media or buildup of
lactic acid or any kind of metabolic
substances
the ph might fall dramatically to six
as a result we would understand
immediately
we have to subculture so let me give you
a quick idea
about some color changes and
possible interpretation so if ph
is 7 then everything is fine
seven to seven point four everything is
fine
now look at this situation when the
media is slightly orangish
so you need to change it within 24 hours
and it's okay
but when the media is media ph is 6.5
then immediate change is important
or there could be one contamination as
well when the ph
is 7.8 there might be some problem with
co2 supply so this
is kind of a thumb rule now
once we understand when to do a
subculture
now we can understand how to do a
subculture
so let's hop into the cell culture lab
now first we have to examine the cells
under the microscope
for its confluency we have to ensure
that there is no contamination and the
color change is not due to contamination
so once we have examined that part
visually we can decide that we have to
subculture right now
and all this process has to be done
under a sterile cell culture hood
so now let's hop into the sterile cell
culture hole
here you can first take out the media
which is now yellowish in color
after taking out this media you can
rinse the cells
with pbs and these cells are adhered to
the bottom of these
cell culture flask now if it's a
non-adherent cell
it would be slightly difficult then
generally people put trypsin
which would dislodge the cell from this
bottom
after putting trypsin you wait for some
time or incubate the cell for some time
and then you resuspend the cell
and try to take out the trypsinite cell
using this pipeline now
these cells which are trypsinized
are added to a media so this would block
the trypsin activity
and trypsin activity is not good for
cells
so obviously after uh blocking the
trypsin activity
we have to centrifuge it and obtain the
cell pellet
this media which contains some amount of
trypsin has to be thrown away
and fresh media has to be added
the cells need to be resuspended in this
fresh media
then some amount of cells need to be
seeded into a fresh
plus containing fresh media and this is
how
we perform subculture so i hope you
understand the subculturing technique
and these basic aspects of cell culture
now there is a cell culture playlist you
can watch all these videos
now let me tell you that you can also
support my channel
in patreon the link would be given in
the description
if you are indian viewer you can support
my channel
by donating some amount of money even
it's nominal
your donation matters a lot for our
channel
so you can use this qr code to pay me
and you can also take my courses in
unacademy which is india's biggest
learning platform
and please don't forget to like share
and subscribe
thank you